SPEAKER: Growth happens fast.
Since we last talked,
Critter Junction
just bought another
gaming company
to enable cross-platform gaming.
Now you can raise
virtual pets with friends
on PC, Android, and
internet-connected calculators.
Let's look at how
Critter Junction was
able to quickly integrate this
new company's infrastructure
into their stack.
When Critter Junction first
bought the new company,
there was one major concern.
They had an entirely
different Cloud provider
and a different architecture.
Critter Junction switched
over to containers
and microservices.
The new company's tech
stack was a monolith
taking over the entire VM.
Critter Junction uses a
cloud native approach.
The new company was
hosting everything on-prem.
Critter Junction really wanted
to acquire the new company
to add its cross-platform
functionality
to its own offering.
But everyone involved
thought it would
take too much time
and engineering
efforts to actually integrate.
Luckily, Critter
Junction called us
before they turned
down this opportunity
to expand their offering while
still being able to scale
and manage diverse systems.
We told them about Google
Cloud's Anthos platform,
which lets you run apps
anywhere using GKE.
The idea is to provide
a single platform
for managing all Kubernetes
workloads wherever they are,
including on-prem
and other clouds.
This works because
Migrate from Anthos
can turn VMs and physical
servers into a Kubernetes
pod, which can run
inside of a cluster just
like any other pod.
Once Critter Junction decided to
go ahead with this acquisition,
they had a Google Cloud partner
solution team come on site
to help them set up
a GKE on-prem cluster
and migrate over their
newly acquired company's
existing infrastructure.
Next the team helped them set
up an Anthos Service Mesh,
a fully managed service
mesh to handle communication
between their on-prem
cluster and their current GKE
cluster, which allowed the
on-prem workloads to be visible
inside of the Cloud console.
From this point they could
manage all their workloads
in one place, enable
cluster load balancing,
and scale their services
beyond a single cluster
or environment.
Originally, Critter Junction
was hesitant to acquire
a new company even though
it made business sense,
because they were afraid
of the risks and complexity
of managing a hybrid solution.
But Anthos let Critter Junction
manage the diverse workloads
they acquired from one
place without having
to move them to Google Cloud.
They could migrate existing
VMs into containers,
get unified traffic management,
and scale their operations
and take on new
business opportunities.
So that's a wrap for this
episode of Season of Scale.
Check out the link below
to learn more about Anthos,
and stay tuned to
learn more about how
Critter Junction
continues to improve
the design of their app
architecture and dev processes.
And remember, always
be architecting.